تدخل الحرب على غزه شهرها الخامس بعد اكثر
من 120 يوما كانت ثقيله على اهل القطاع
تظهر ملامح صفقه تعد على نار هادئه بناء
على ما اصبح يعرف بالاطار العام لاتفاقيه
التبادل بوسطه قطريه وجهود مصريه وامريكيه
من الدوحه اتت الاشارات الاولى لرد حماس
رد ارفقته حماس بملاحظات لكنه يبعث على
التفاؤل بحسب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخ
الط قد
استلمنا ردا من حركه حماس بشان الاطار
العام لاتفاقيه الاطراف بشان ما يخص
الرهان يتضمن الرد بعض الملاحظات على
الاطار ولكن في مجمله رد ايجابي على
الاطار ولكن نظرا
لحساسيه هذه المرحله لا يمكننا الخوف
التفاصيل
ويدعون هذا الرد للتفائل وتم تسليم الرد
للجانب الاسرائيلي يقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انه تلقى رد حماس وسيدرس بعنايه
وسينقل الى الجانب الاسرائيلي خلال زيارته
الاربعاء الى تل ابيب حيث سيناقش هناك مع
حكومه
الطوارئ كل ما يسعني قوله هو اننا تلقينا
ردا من حماس على المقترح ونحن ندرسه
بعنايه وسنطلق الاسرائيليين عليه كما انني
ساتابع النقاش معهم الاربعاء هناك سنبذل
قصار جهدنا للوصول الى اتفاق يمضي بنا
قدما ليس فقط لتجديد الهدنه وانما
لتوسيعها واخراج الرهائن
حركه حماس من جهتها قالت انها سلمت ردها
للوسطاء في قطر ومصر وفقا لبيان الحركه
فان الرد الصيغه بعد مشاورات داخليه ومع
فصائل المقاومه في غزه تؤكد حماس انها
تعاملت مع المقترح بايجابيه وبما يضمن وقف
اطلاق النار الشامله والتام وانهاء
العدوان على قط قطاع غزه والاغاثه
والايواء والاعمار ورفع الحصار عن القطاع
وانجاز عمليه تبادل للاسرى والمقترح الذي
يجري الحديث عنه وضعت خطوطه العريضه خلال
اجتماع رباعي في باريس في الس 277 من
يناير الماضي الذي وضع اطارا لما يمكن ان
يؤدي لاتفاق تبادل مصحوب بالتزامات اخرى
تقدر اسرائيل عدد اسرها لدى فصائل
المقاومه في غزه بنحو
136 يتحدث الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن اطلاق
سراح عشرات منهم بحيث تعطى الاولويه
للاطفال والنساء والمرضى مقابل وقف لاطلاق
النار لاسابيع في غزه والافراج عن عدد
كبير من الاسرى الفلسطينيين وبينما لا
تزال هناك خلافات مهمه يتعين حلها يبض
المفاوضون تفاؤلا حذرا بان التوصل الى
اتفاق النهائي في متناول اليد وكانت جهود
قطريه مصريه امريكيه قد ارست في ال 24ش من
نوفمبر الماضي وقفا انسانيا لاطلاق النار
استمر اسبوعا افرجت خلاله المقاومه عن 105
رهاء بينهم 80 اسرائيليا مقابل اطلاق
اسرائيل سراح 240 اسيرا فلسطينيا وادخال
مساعدات انسانيه محدوده للقطاع واذا يتحدث
البيت الابيض عن مقترح جاد بشان هدنه
مطوله في غزه ستمكن من اطلاق سراح الرخاء
يستبق نتنياهو وصول بلينكن لتل ابيب
بالقول ان اسرائيل في طريقها الى تحقيق
النصر المطلق في غزه ولن تتوقف حتى تحققه
مجددا رفضه القاطع لاي طلب بوقف القتال
وانسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه من كامل
القطاع ثمه من يعارض رؤيه نتنياهو هذه اذ
يبدو جليا الانقسام داخل مجلس الحرب بشان
المضي نحو صفقه مع حماس مسؤولون حاليون
وسابقون في المساد والجيش يرون بضروره ان
تدفع اسرائيل الاثمان المطلوبه وتعجل
بالافراج عن رهائنها في غزه خصوصا وانها
لم تفلح بعد اربعه اشهر من القتال في
الافراج عن اي منهم حيا سوى من خرجوا في
اتفاق
التهدئه